Chris spoon back 12 o'clock okay okay
and we return we're gonna turn the first
toilet over yeah okay now
good boy look underneath and I'll get
over easy easy let's go be careful the
hot fat yes okay so now you see but be
careful of the howling fat yeah yeah now
this is absolutely crucial that we get
that color on the Scot and that's the
difference between shouting and boiling
oh my god it's hot right Chris yeah
you're even sweating yo come on Big Boy
let's go trust me okay way down then
right Janet how are the skull up yeah Oh
Gorgon yeah how the scallops good and
I'm cooking on an auger yeah I know I
got its own kind of personality a bit
like you have I'll see you in February
oh no you know they'll be fine then we
just be five minutes seconds longer what
not saying it's your I'll go the same
ages you funnily enough Gordon it was a
lot younger
okay great just ask him right yeah okay
good right Chris lemon did she said
she's cooking that song right lemon row
below okay come on anybody home
roll that I've never done this it's not
ever this is what gets the juice out
pips out and willing to drop a touch of
lemon juice on top of the scallops one
two three all the way back round again
okay
now okay scallops onto a plate yes and
half-dragged good boy out and drain now
you don't overcook them ah rather you
haven't slightly undercooked and
overcooked it overcook they're rubber so
really be sure to make sure you take
them out early right Chris full plates
let's go big boy four plates yet full
plate okay here we go like that small
plate yeah whole plate that's a large
plate all right
maybe where you can come look but that's
a start plate for me right last food
come on laughing good boy
let's go yep laughter right that's the
last food mixer salsa mixer Sasha one
nice spoon of salsa in the center of the
plate what we're looking for is that
really nice marble effect okay yeah this
a word of warning yeah you're serving my
mum yeah yeah girl I'm very very
concerned about that nice to tell is
your mum don't weirdly he's not happy
okay one nice spoon in the middle and
then from there yes three scallops on
top of the salsa
don't be bossed okay okay well done I
think I might have missed out on some
good okay good
three scallops I think one let's go to
three Chris Murray yeah for three to
twelve okay look that vicious look
roasty scallops poor tomato yes roasted
scallops with tomato-basil salsa done
yeah